here among the mountains and mores of
northern Scotland is a bird that
embodies the best elements of the
greatest Raptors the golden eagle has a
beak that can rip flesh like a blade
it's powerful feet and dagger-like
talents have the strength to crush the
skull of its victims
yet the Golden Eagle wage is an
uncertain war for survival against prey
evolve to vanish into the landscape
in winter these Highlands are often
snow-covered
but the snow can come and go just in a
matter of days for the mountain hair
this can be treacherous molting their
colors to match the seasons this pair
melts into the white landscape
they freeze when the hungry Raptor
passes overhead
but without the cover of snow they stand
out cruelly against the brown Hills the
Eagle singles one out
if the hair turns uphill it could take
away the Raptors advantage the chance to
strike from above
the hair that took the high road
survives the Eagle seems to be at the
pinnacle of Raptor evolution but by no
means is that a perch rather it means
keeping up with the eternal deaths
between predator and prey